I guess my penis wanted pvping it's dumb
it's dumb [ __ ] 2020 happy new year up by
the way and honestly um I see life in HD
I walk out and everything's crisp and
clean I'm trying to be present I'm
trying to be mindful and and um I'm
dealing with
I honestly the last September October
November were the darkest times in
recent years and I feel like I'm out of
the [ __ ] tunnel I'm out in the light
when I see you guys I don't get angry I
used to get so angry when I saw you two
specifically I don't know what it was
not Gilbert especially that oh my god I
used to get when I saw your beady white
[ __ ] oppressive face oppressive face
yeah yeah I used to get so angry where I
have to go to see hi George
and I would rip you apart but I saw you
today it was pleasant to see you a
little a little bit you close the garage
on him oh yeah yeah because you were
driving up and I go I'm gonna close the
garage on them doesn't matter I'm still
gonna do that stuff to you but there is
more of a pleasant feeling that I have
with you um I think partly is because
you know when I was high I didn't see
Steve at all my brother and him and I
had been hanging out and it's been
really fun kalila and I have been
communicating a lot better I feel like
there's growth there I don't know much
about you but I do enjoy you a lot you
brought sandwiches of the house and I
really appreciate that that's it's
selfless and unlike you know it is like
it is like me la bougie Asians I got you
that fancy thank you go still like
events and stuff and wears like suits
with other Asians and he like you know
what I mean they have their own but
we're like the grimy agents babe and
he's I know we could invite addition we
got invited to the Daniel Dae Kim
Chinese New Year party I can't go
because I'm gonna be an
Vaughn Daniel Dae Kim hosted a Chinese
New Year party no he has one coming up
and we were invite he called me directly
and he says you want to go I love to go
but I can't go now
Gilbert girls are like private concerts
yeah I'll go to a private concert with
you too babe we can go we just don't go
you got to be less beefy for those of it
you're not a lot okay you're not a lot
of caller that might be beef she's I
told her and she made some gains in a
good way though yeah Danny I say that
upstairs that's like the first thing he
said he's like whoa I thought she was
lifting like lifting more why because
you have more thigh meat and more back
meet my ask me I love it so um one of
the events I had with my brother is we I
drove all the way to Walnut was where
his girlfriend lives and this is
something I would never do in the
intervention reign in it was super
raining hard it was that midnight
showing and they wanted me to meet me at
some dessert place in walnut and I drove
in this rain met them I Lonnie and my
brother and then we saw rise of
Skywalker's and um I have to be honest I
gave the the movie Abbie would you give
it Oh they'd be right I now tell you why
because the last Jedi was so disastrous
I thought that there was so many too
many questions that were never gonna be
answered that I thought it was an
impossible task to do the third movie
and I thought JJ Abrams pulled it off to
the best of his ability it's still as a
whole a terrible franchise the trilogy
is weird it doesn't make any sense
none of it you know what spoiler can be
to spoilers that's been out for a while
mylar okay the healing what the [ __ ] if
you could heal if you could [ __ ] heal
Jedi's could hear then Luke when his
hand got chopped I'll remember remember
hear that bandage it up but he was
shivering remember what went you know he
was upside down in Cloud City
we're upside down and he was shivering
you have the ability right maybe he
wasn't evolved enough as a Jedi back
then do you think that is and then I
feel like kylo she should have killed
him right when he died right do back and
forth back and forth make out yeah he
could have come yeah yeah that would
that that relationship we're eating in
the Box were you bothered by that iowa's
I saw it coming and I'm gonna say
something he's not no it's not gonna be
controversial I'm not saying it for any
controversy has nothing to do with the
race just like hear me I just don't
think that I didn't believe the finn and
rey because I thought that thin had a
crush on her and that that was gonna be
a thing yeah and it has nothing to do
with it just I just didn't the
relationship was I know what they were
trying to do what was even before Rose
and I think Finn was Finn and Poe a gay
relationship that's what people were
saying I don't think Disney was like
whoa we're not ready for that yeah
because I did think I I did read the Poe
was gay that's what people thought was
gonna be Finn in Poe possibly
oh yeah I'm not into that but I'm also
not Finn and the chubby Asian either is
that wrong to say by the way she's a
great actress love her not only is she
great acts acts actress the kind of [ __ ]
that people were saying online ads mean
is so [ __ ] me listen to me okay this
girl great actress right if I ever have
anything that I develop if I could get
her I would get her she's not good mm-hm
um the kind of things that people were
saying it's like listen you're a girl
you land a Star Wars movie you memorize
the lines that they give you
you can't improvise this is a [ __ ]
Star Wars movie you do exactly what they
say the movie comes out there's nothing
what can she do you know what can she
can't
[ __ ] do anything she everyone would
do it right no there's no one on planet
earth even if you're not an actor
did he said to Jordan would they said to
you you we're gonna give you ten lines
in the next Star Wars movie would you do
it exactly everyone in the room you to
write so she does this movie and that
people are saying that all this [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's like so mean and hateful it's
like you know did I like that part no
but it's not her fault she read the
script yeah she read the lines of the
[ __ ] thing she's a good actress you
can tell when you're watching the last
Jedi you're like oh that she's [ __ ]
convincing you know me it's just I just
didn't like the part right but like
[ __ ] trolls out there men are so mean
you're also fine you guys say things
about me sometime did you read stuff
about me yeah yeah why do you do that
I've read stuff stuff about me why
you've read some I've read stuff about
you
like what like here's this I was just
scrolling through the internet no I was
reading on the internet and I found out
I I could handle it I'm a numeric so I
was online yeah and I saw this article
called TV scene-stealers of 2019 on that
list was Alice from Batwoman Lola from
big mouth yeah mo Collins from the
walking dead
she's go Pendergast chillin it I love
her baby Yoda of the mandalorian the
high attachment right now fantastic
right before him yeah his gin played by
Bobby Lee which wrote me for that wait
did she did he prompt you to say that no
I was scrolling it was Google top all
right I'm blushing now you [ __ ]
[ __ ] I was looking for a [ __ ]
compliment you [ __ ] Duke you [ __ ]
all right right and then you put beef in
that population it's [ __ ] rich beef
looks to be be flicks whatever
it's coolest though yeah it's a coulis
yeah part of it's funny because when
somebody is the writer and producer sent
me that link about you know I'm a scene
whatever the scene stealer and it's so
funny because when I read things like
that I can't accept it but bad [ __ ]
online some [ __ ] some [ __ ] guy who
lives in Michigan or wherever right I
don't know what it is yeah yeah um some
guy from Indiana is that better
okay says like you know you're not funny
you're you don't mean I can't understand
why people think you're funny you know
whatever and I take that to heart some
[ __ ] loser
yes that's right you're a [ __ ] loser
all right but there's something good
happens so on what I'm trying to do is
um be mindful and be authentic and I
want to really try to you know what take
the good things but don't get too
wrapped up in it and the best thing
don't get too wrapped up in it it's just
it is what it is it is what it is that's
the thing I've been trying to um I know
it sounds hokey pokey